- Basketball at Winnebago is
one of the biggest things here.
A lot of these kids, that's
all they got is basketball.
The town of Winnebago,
population's about 1500.
The Winnebago Public
School is probably at 250.
There ain't a whole lot to do here
besides play basketball.
Basically, all they got is a gym to go to.
So, I opened it for 'em.
(techno music)
(light piano music)
When you come play for
Winnebago High School,
we expect to compete every
year for a state title.
My name is Jeffrey Berridge,
and I am the head coach at
Winnebago Public School.
Winter's in Winnebago, it's
cold but everybody knows
it's basketball season, so
that means the gym's hot.
It's goin’, and they love it.
Basketball here is really big.
It plays an important part
in our community of Native Americans.
Rezball is just our version
of a really fast-paced basketball game.
We call it Rezball.
It's comin' from the
Reservation, obviously,
it's a short for Rez.
If you miss a shot, you miss a shot.
Move on.
- Yeah, I got it.
- [Jeffrey] I expect a lot from these boys,
and I push them to be great.
Because I don't just
wanna see them playing
on this court, I wanna
go watch them in college.
That's my ultimate goal
is just to get these kids
to bigger places.
- [Crowd] Defense!
Defense!
(piano music)
- [Jeffrey] Some of
these kids have it hard.
Broken homes, alcohol, gambling,
all that stuff comes into
play on the Reservations.
And basketball does save them.
I always tell 'em, "You
take care of that ball,
"that ball's gonna take care of you."
- You got knock down open shot.
Knock down open shot.
- [Jeffrey] And I'm walkin' proof of it.
I'm from here, I played
ball at the college level,
and it's just what I bring to these kids
and show them that it's possible.
D'von Lapointe, he's
a senior guard for me,
so this year he's probably
the best player on the team.
Everything's gonna go through him.
- [D'von] Basketball, it's my medicine.
Just helps me get away from my problems
for a little bit.
(crowd cheering)
It's our stress reliever.
Just play basketball.
When I put that jersey on,
I try to carry the
tradition for the people
that already built it.
We're just tryin' to
keep this legacy goin'.
- Alright, so let's go out there
and let's have some fun
and give these guys a show.
- On three!
- One, two, three!
(crowd cheering)
- The fans of Winnebago,
really, it gets crazy.
They're loud, they're yelling.
I mean, it's just, it's
a great atmosphere.
(crowd cheering)
The fans come to watch because they see
how hard the boys work on the court.
Winnebago is a very special place.